ryan hillsbergs a former cia
intelligence officer
spyx.com analyst and a director of
corporate security at a global biotech
company
so this is a pretty brave mission
that the u.s government pulled off
was it worth it
hi jesse thanks for having me on your
show you know what this is something
that
is done normally with our liaison
partners and countries that need our
support
and a lot of the training that is
provided
it's really some of the best training in
the world
and
really some of the reports that we've
received about what happened after 2014
about cia's paramilitary officers
entering ukraine and helping them train
and and provide that support you know i
think it's necessary and this is
something that has
happens regularly around the world
and i'm glad to hear um that you know
these reports have come out and that we
were doing something uh being preemptive
being proactive and trying to be
preventative and really at the end of
the day
it's about
protecting our sources protecting our
methods and a lot of the training that
we do do it's clandestine it's secret
and that's why we really haven't known
what was going on there
before the last few weeks
how big of a difference was the cia
paramilitary training
and do you think it has more to do with
that training or more to do with the
ferocious
and patriotic spirit of the ukrainian
people
i definitely think that the patriotism
and the ferocious spirit of the
ukrainians that's really what from what
i've been able to tell uh first and
foremost what they have to their
advantage uh also having been through a
lot of cia training whether it's at the
farm or other locations
it really is the way that they train
people they want to make the training so
difficult so stressful and so strenuous
that anything that you see or do or
experience in the real world will
hopefully be easy now it's a different
matter of course in a war zone
environment
but i can attest after being in the
agency for 13 years nothing i really did
in the real world was as difficult as
what i was put through in training and i
think that's a really good way to train
people how do you think i'd do at the
farm ryan
you know it just depends um it's all
it's mental you know a lot of people
think that it's a lot of physical
training and there's a little bit of
that aspect
but it's it really is a mental uh
education
and
you know you never know uh you have to
be able to live and and work in the gray
people that have a black and white
mentality or black and white um
perspective of the world
often times struggle uh to get through
the farm
but if you you can deal with ambiguity
if you live
and work in the gray in terms of your
mindset and and your outlook of the
world
you're you're on the right track and
you'll be more successful thank you so
much ryan hillsberg we appreciate your
service hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else